لقد وجدت أن جزء الطعام في اليابان ربما يكون
أحد الأشياء الأكثر روعة
وما عرفته هو أن الناس يتحدثون
عن جينات طول العمر ما أعرفه الآن هو
أننا ربما جميعًا لدينا
جينات طول العمر التي تحتاج الجينات إلى
تنشيطها.  بقولك أنك
تعلم أن لدينا مخططًا للمنزل ،
فلدينا جميعًا نفس مخطط
المنزل ولكننا الآن سنبدأ
في وضع المواد الخام وبناء
المنزل الفعلي نفسه في هذه الحالة
الجينات التي لديك هي المخطط
و  المكونات النيئة هي
أطعمة معينة وتجد أن
نوع النظام الغذائي الأساسي في اليابان يميل إلى تنشيط
هذه الجينات ، وهناك سبب وراء
الحفاظ على الأطعمة مثل البطيخ المر
وتوارثها لأجيال في
مكان مثل اليابان كانوا يعرفون بشكل بديهي
أن هذا الطعام كان بطريقة ما  من الجيد لك
أن يطلقوا عليها اسم ابنها المعدني ،
تبلغ من العمر ما يقرب من مائة عام ، إنها تبلغ من العمر 97 عامًا بالطريقة
التي تحرك بها السرعة التي تمشي
بها بالابتسامة والطاقة التي قالت
إن قلبها يشعر بها  يبدو أنها كانت
تبلغ من العمر 20 عامًا ، ولا يوجد دليل على وجود مرض على
الإطلاق ونظرة صحية حقًا
للحياة.
إنهم يأكلون ، هل يمكنك أن تضع
يديك هكذا ، إنه لأمر مدهش على
الأرجح أنني أقوم بالطريقة
التي يقتربون بها من الشيخوخة على جميع
كبار السن الذين يتم تبجيلهم وحكمتهم
يبدو أن لديهم المزيد من الهدف
والحياة ومن ثم من الواضح أن شخصًا ما مثل
غيبوبة عليها  هذه
الدائرة الاجتماعية الضيقة المذهلة وهذه الأنشطة
مثل الرقص والغناء والتي
بالتأكيد تجعلها أصغر سنًا تؤذيك